Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Vous le savez, j'adore partager avec vous
mes connaissances sur les animaux.
Aujourd'hui, je vous propose mon top
5 des animaux dotés d'un super-pouvoir ?
Ça vous dit ?
Alors c'est parti !
1 :  L'écureuil roux.
Ce sympathique rongeur
qui vit dans nos forêts
n'a rien à envier à Chip, le génial écureuil
de Krypto et les super-animaux.
Il possède une mémoire d'éléphant !
Vous le savez peut-être,
les écureuils n'hibernent pas.
Pour tenir le choc en hiver, ils constituent des réserves.
Des noisettes, des glands, des insectes ou des champignons
qu'ils enfouissent
un peu partout dans le sol !
Ils peuvent constituer
jusqu'à 3000 réserves.
Des cachettes qu'ils doivent mémoriser. Pas simple, me direz vous.
Et pourtant, les écureuils y parviennent.
Comment font-ils ?
On a longtemps pensé que cette prouesse
était liée à un odorat
particulièrement développé.
C'est faux !
Les scientifiques ont découvert
qu'ils possèdent
une mémoire spatiale exceptionnelle.
Pour se souvenir de ses cachettes,
l'écureuil roux adopte une stratégie
appelée "chunking", que l'on peut traduire
par "mémorisation par blocs".
Il commence par entasser ses réserves
en un seul endroit,
puis il les répartit dans différents lieux
en fonction de leur nature.
Les noisettes sont stockées dans une zone.
Les champignons dans une autre etc, etc...
Il se forge ainsi
une carte mentale de ses cachettes.
Ce qui lui permet de retrouver
ses provisions sans aucune difficulté !
Cerise sur le gâteau, ce petit malin
dissimule les aliments à haute
valeur nutritive le plus loin
possible de la source de nourriture.
De cette manière, il minimise les chances
de se faire dérober son trésor.
Quel panache !
2 : Le lézard basilic.
À vue de nez, rien ne le distingue
des multiples espèces de lézards
qui peuplent les forêts d'Amérique
centrale.
Il possède une jolie couleur
verdoyante, une longue queue
et deux aigrettes qui lui donnent l'allure
d'un petit dinosaure.
Et pourtant, Basiliscus Plumifrons,
c'est son nom savant, n'est
pas un lézard comme les autres.
Il possède un super-pouvoir unique
chez les reptiles.
Ce lézard vit à proximité des cours d'eau.
Lorsqu'il se sent menacé,
plutôt que de prendre ses jambes
à son cou et de s'enfuir dans la forêt,
il se dresse sur ses pattes arrière
et se met à courir... sur l'eau !
Ce qui lui vaut un autre surnom :
le Lézard Jésus-Christ !
Et pour cause,
selon les évangiles,
Jésus aurait marché sur l'eau.
Cette aptitude est d'autant
plus surprenante
que ce petit saurien de 90 cm
peut peser jusqu'à 200 g et 200 g,
ce n'est pas rien !
En toute logique...
il devrait couler à pic !
Alors comment fait-il ?
Il n'y a aucun miracle
dans cette histoire...
Cette prouesse est liée
à la forme de ses pattes arrière :
elles sont pourvues de très longs doigts.
Lorsque ceux-ci sont déployés et écartés,
ils offrent au lézard
une grande surface de contact avec l'eau :
un peu comme des palmes !
Par ailleurs, lorsque ses pattes frappent
la surface de l'eau,
une bulle d'air se forme en dessous,
ce qui ralentit l'enfoncement.
Ajoutez à cela une foulée extrêmement
rapide :
pas plus de 70 ms / pas,
et le lézard parvient à courir
sur l'eau sans aucune difficulté !
En revanche, s'il ralentit,
il doit finir à la nage...
Aucun problème pour lui,
ce champion est même capable
de tenir une dizaine de minutes en apnée.
Puisque nous sommes sous l'eau,
restons-y avec notre troisième animal
aux super-pouvoirs,
une transformiste de
génie : la pieuvre mimétique.
Ce céphalopode a été
découvert en 1998
sur les côtes indonésiennes.
Il vit sur les fonds sableux et mesure
une soixantaine de centimètres.
Comme la plupart de ses congénères,
cette pieuvre est capable
de changer de couleur
en un clin d'œil grâce à
des cellules spécialisées sur sa peau.
Ce tour de passe-passe
lui permet de chasser
et de se protéger d'éventuels prédateurs.
Mais Thaumoctopus Mimicus, de son nom savant,
ne se contente pas
de se fondre dans le décor.
Elle est aussi capable de prendre la forme
des animaux qui partagent son habitat.
Pour imiter une sole par exemple,
elle regroupe ses huit bras en un faisceau
de la même forme que l'animal.
Elle ressemble alors
à une sole plate qui ondule dans l'eau.
Pour ressembler au serpent de mer,
un prédateur dont le venin est mortel,
elle change ses rayures brunes
et blanches en rayures jaunes et noires.
Puis elle enfouit sa tête ainsi que six
de ses tentacules dans le sable...
Il ne lui reste plus qu'à agiter
frénétiquement
ses deux derniers tentacules
pour simuler la présence du reptile.
C'est à s'y méprendre !
Et cette stratégie s'avère payante :
les prédateurs réfléchissent
à deux fois avant d'attaquer.
Ironie de l'histoire : les scientifiques
viennent d'identifier un petit poisson
capable de prendre la forme
des tentacules de la pieuvre mimétique.
Le Stalix Histrio bénéficie
ainsi de la protection,
probablement involontaire,
de cet as du déguisement.
Tel est pris
qui croyait prendre.
Retour sur Terre pour notre quatrième animal aux super-pouvoirs.
Je vais vous parler d'un insecte.
Malgré son poids plume,
il envoie du lourd : le bousier taureau !
Il s'agit d'un petit coléoptère,
de la famille des scarabées
que l'on trouve en Europe et en Asie.
Il tient son nom de la grande paire de
cornes qui ornent la tête de certains mâles.
Mais ce n'est pas à ce niveau que se niche son super-pouvoir...
Il se cache... dans ses biscotos.
Le bousier est en effet
doté d'une force herculéenne !
Ce minuscule insecte, qui ne pèse
que quelques grammes, est capable
de pousser des boules d'excréments
1 140 fois plus lourdes que lui.
C'est comme si je parvenais à déplacer une roche
de 80 tonnes,
l'équivalent de 2 semi-remorques.
Évidemment c'est impossible..
même pour l'homme le plus fort du monde !
Alors, comment fait-il ? Eh bien pour réussir cet exploit,
l'insecte commence par fabriquer une énorme boule
composée de déjections
qu'il collecte dans son environnement.
De la crotte d'éléphant, par exemple.
Une fois que la boule est bien formée,
et bien compacte,
il prend appui sur le sol à l'aide
de ses pattes avant.
Puis il pousse son fardeau avec ses pattes
arrière.
Bref, pour avancer il recule.
Vous me suivez ?
Et ça marche... Enfin, ça roule !
Alors vous allez me dire : pourquoi ce
diable de bousier passe-t-il ses journées
à pousser des matières fécales ?
Eh bien, il se trouve que c'est un
coprophage
un animal qui se nourrit
uniquement d'excréments !
Chacun ses goûts.
C'est aussi un insecte très utile.
En enterrant sa nourriture,
il joue un rôle essentiel
dans la fertilisation des sols
et la dispersion des graines
qu'elle contient.
Rien ne se perd, tout se recycle.
Cinq,
on finit avec un feu d'artifice,
je vous présente Apogonidae, un poisson qui pète le feu !
Enfin je devrais plutôt dire qui crache le feu !
Il émet de magnifiques
jets de lumière bleue
qui sortent de sa bouche
et font penser à des boules de feu.
Cela lui vaut un autre surnom :
le poisson cracheur de lumière !
Ce petit poisson transparent
vit dans les profondeurs océaniques.
Un monde sans lumière
ou la discrétion est de rigueur.
Ne pas être vu dans son environnement
est une question de vie ou de mort.
Dans ce cas, pourquoi met-il tout en œuvre
pour se faire repérer ?
S'agirait-il d'une stratégie ingénieuse
pour impressionner ses prédateurs ?
Pas du tout.
Au contraire même. Lorsqu'il
produit ce jet lumineux, Apogonidae
est en réalité victime
d'un petit crustacé très indigeste :
L' Ostracode !
Sentant sa dernière heure venue,
le crustacé déclenche
un mécanisme de défense plutôt brillant.
Il s'allume. L'Ostracode
déclenche une réaction chimique
bioluminescente
semblable à celle des vers luisants.
Elle met en jeu une molécule spéciale
qu'on appelle la luciférase
qui réagit avec l'oxygène
en émettant de la lumière.
Or il se trouve
que cette lumière, très vive, représente
un vrai danger pour notre poisson...
Souvenez-vous, il est transparent !
Eclairé de l'intérieur,
le voilà tout à coup
repérable par ses prédateurs.
Pour sauver sa peau,
ou plutôt ses écailles, Apogonidae
n'a d'autre choix que de régurgiter
l'intrus dans un rot magistral.
Celui-ci prend alors la forme
d'un jet de lumière du plus bel effet.
La gourmandise est un vilain défaut.
Apogonidae
nous en apporte la preuve lumineuse !
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo jusqu'au bout,
c'est le meilleur soutien
que vous pouvez apporter à la chaîne.
Et si vous connaissez d'autres animaux aux super-pouvoirs qui auraient leur place
dans ce top, ne vous privez pas,
laissez un commentaire.
J'ai hâte de vous lire.
En attendant, je vous invite à découvrir
les super-pouvoirs de Krypto et ses amis
en salle le 27 juillet.
Ah,
j'allais oublier :
n'hésitez pas non plus à vous abonner !
A très bientôt,
chers Épicurieuses
et Épicurieux.